[Music]
obama has come out in favor
and endorsed the uh uh gay marriage you
still follow the news
i do follow the news thank you pal and
uh and it's getting so much attention
and uh i want to hear your take on this
momentous event what many people say is
historic
well of course i think it's ridic that
it took that long
um you know this mitt romney is going
around the country
pretending that marriage is this secret
concept that only applies when you
ejaculate in a vagina
this
come on it's two in the afternoon you
need to be adults
i'm just i'm just shocked you know my
wedding vows
yeah it's like those are sacred words
so now he's going around he of course uh
he's the first gay president
yeah did you see the cover yes the cover
of newsweek says that obama is the first
gay president are you some people are
thinking this is a little bit uh maybe
i don't know what that means i mean i i
understand that it's
andrew sullivan who is a friend does
real time often
great thinker i haven't read the article
yet uh
because it's two in the afternoon uh
but uh it it comes from what they tony
morrison years ago said clinton was the
first black president
remember that but she said he was the
first black president because
she said so many things about him were
similar to the black experience
single mother working class grew up poor
then she said you know saxophone playing
as if all black people do that
right um mcdonald's eating you know
that's what she said so he was but okay
so clinton was like black people for
those reasons
what about obama is i don't understand
how this translates why is he the first
what does he do that's gay
yeah i i you tell me it's uh there i
think uh
what's interesting too is that the the
cover of the magazine portrays him
i i saw it with salon or or or one of
these uh
someone said it they've made him a gay
angel well they put
a halo a multicolored halo over his head
why not
just short shorts and a penis popsicle
in his hands i mean
[Applause]
can you imagine that photo shoot just
hold it mr president
just hold it it's for the photo it'll
make sense but it's also ridiculous
because mitt romney i mean here he is
talking about how marriage
you know goes back 3 000 years is what
all republicans say by the way that you
know it's the cornerstone
right of civilization which is one of
those rectum-derived statistics
just something they completely
i'm saying they just pulled it out of
their ass ladies and gentlemen it's just
you're right i like i like rectum
derived yeah
that's a very specific kind of think
tank yeah that's a big thing
that's exactly what happened but uh it's
not that's
one thing and also of all the people to
be making this claim that marriage is
between one man and
one a mormon yeah between one man
except for my grandfather who went to
mexico specifically to get away from a
country
that said you have to have a marriage
that's only one they went to mexico the
romneys
i mean mormonism i don't want to get off
on mormonism you know how i feel about
religion it's all batshit but i mean
this is
this is a religion
this is a religion that is so stupid
that tom cruise would not join it
[Applause]
and glenn did
so we should look at the celebrities who
decided not to join
according to mormon dogma and you know
how you could tell it's mormon dogma
it's strapped to the roof of the car all
right
you're booing me
[Laughter]
whenever we get on the subject of
religion i know this is a passionate
subject for you but i think you know i
was raised catholic and i think who
might have
who am i to throw stones in other
religions when you eat a cookie and you
turn into jesus and all that you know
it's it's there are people who can
stand outside any religion and say that
is very strange i was raised catholic
too
you don't turn into jesus
that's how it was explained to me
i thought i was jesus now
that's the reason i went to church time
and time again
but that's it's very refreshing to hear
you knock religion that way usually i'm
all alone on this issue it's nice to see
someone in the mainstream media
you call this the mainstream
where the hell have you been